[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas
están cansados no bueno porque lo voy a
poner a trabajar porque me han dicho que
no debo de empezar una plática con una
pregunta que pueda hacer sentir incómoda
al auditorio y que creen que voy a hacer
le voy a hacer una pregunta porque como
los saludé al principio entonces ya
puedo hacer la pregunta verdad esta es
la segunda parte y esta es la pregunta
que les quiero hacer quién de ustedes se
considera que tiene determinación cuando
hablo de determinación les estoy
preguntando que cuando se ponen una meta
un objetivo trabajan incansablemente
hasta llegar a ello levante la mano
quien se considera determinado muy bien
porque tenemos algunas personas
determinadas los que dejaron la mano
abajo no se preocupen ahorita vamos a
empezar a desmantelar los a estos pero
lo primero que tenemos que hacer con los
que levantaron la mano es que saquemos a
ese grupo que quizás por ejemplo el año
pasado no se puso ninguna meta ni ningún
propósito porque es muy sencillo decir
que eres determinado cuando no hacen
nada verdad es decir hay un buen dicho
que dice que el problema de no hacer
nada es que nunca sabes cuándo has
terminado
entonces hay otro segundo bloque que
tenemos que sacar que son las personas
que quizás sí se pusieron alguna meta
pero por algún motivo no la alcanzaron
hubo algo en el proceso que no les
permitió alcanzar y ya los que nos
quedan pues tendríamos que ver qué tipo
de metas y de propósitos se ponen porque
también muchísima gente me encuentro de
repente en el camino personas que es
sencillo estoy mira súper comprometido o
sea mi meta es despertarme todos los
días
respirando
y yo le digo que ese es en verdad es un
milagro pero la madre naturaleza te
ayuda también no podríamos decir que es
todo de tu parte no entonces
les hago esta pregunta porque lo que
quiero es que me acompañen en este
ratito a platicar un poco acerca de qué
es lo que mueve a la gente a ser
realmente productivo a lograr las metas
a lograr los objetivos desde que era
niño tenía como muchas preguntas veía
cómo la gente los adultos se comportaban
de forma diferente veía como había
algunas personas que tenían poder
adquisitivo bueno y otras no veía
también cómo había algunas personas que
quizás tenían por ejemplo la
determinación de levantarse para ir a
hacer ejercicio mientras por otro lado
había quienes decidían quedarse en cama
viendo tele o comiendo palomitas no veía
también cómo había personas que tenían
como buena actitud y que al mismo tiempo
había personas que siempre estaban
malhumoradas
cuando empecé a checar esto de hecho
déjenme decirles que yo pensaba que la
gente que tenía buena actitud era porque
les salían bien las cosas y por eso
andaba como de buenas andaba positivo
con el tiempo me di cuenta que gracias a
que eran optimistas es que les salían
bien las cosas
si ustedes le preguntan ahorita a
cualquier persona cercana qué es lo que
tienen que hacer para lograr una meta lo
más seguro es que les van a decir pues
ponte a trabajar la mayoría de la gente
lo que dice es trabaja trabaja en el
objetivo que traigas pero si nos ponemos
a pensar con detalle vamos a darnos
cuenta que no sólo es trabajar porque lo
interesante es saber por qué estamos
trabajando la gente cuando está
solamente trabajando aunque se relacione
el trabajo con el logro con los
objetivos con las metas con el poder no
necesariamente es así la vida me ayudó
dándome respuestas esta teoría que
traigo y que les acabo de comentar la
confirme hace poquito con un estudio que
se realizó hace poco en donde se
enlistaron a 38 países y de los 38
países sacaron un promedio de cuántas
horas trabajaban las personas en estos
países como pueden ver estamos en primer
lugar significa que de estos 38 países
según el estudio nosotros somos los que
más trabajamos
si el trabajo está relacionado con la
meta y el poder deberíamos de ser una
potencia mundial
algo nos está pasando nos saque tres
conclusiones cuando vi este estudio el
primero o la primera conclusión estamos
en primer lugar en algo por si se
sentían mal ya estamos en algo en primer
lugar la segunda somos bien trabajadores
no nos los pueden negar porque ahí está
el estudio la tercera el mundo no
entienden nuestra forma de trabajar
porque hacemos como qué hacemos pero
realmente no logramos nada
en esta búsqueda de respuestas les
podría decir que la vida me premió
porque me permitió entrar a trabajar a
una empresa en donde el líder después se
convirtió en un icono de la
productividad a nivel mundial tal vez
algunos de ustedes lo identifiquen
él es stephen covey es el autor de los
siete hábitos de la gente altamente
efectiva trabaje para su empresa durante
algunos años y ahí fue un parteaguas en
mi vida personal y profesional ahí en la
foto de seguro kobe está preguntándose
qué porque yo tengo tanto cabello y él
no
si es si revive se vuelve a morir
un día estábamos en una sesión de
trabajo
y él estaba hablando nos acerca de algún
proyecto nos regaló un libro que había
recién escrito la mayoría le pedimos que
nos firmará el libro casi todos
recibieron un libro en donde decía algo
así como para juan con cariño stephen
covey a mí me entregó el libro y me lo
entrego cerrado y me dijo hay un mensaje
para ti cuando llegue a mi lugar y lo
abrí este era el mensaje decía pedro
continúa bendiciendo vidas
responsabilidad fuerte en
responsabilidad difícil no sólo a través
de él me llegaron los mensajes me han
llegado mensajes
durante toda mi vida con mis padres con
mis hermanos con mi esposa con mis hijas
todos los días me llegan mensajes de que
tengo que buscar la manera de cómo
llevar información positiva y tal vez
por eso es que ahora me dedico a la
parte de la consultoría y la
capacitación con la intención de llevar
esta información
les quiero decir que con kobe aprendí
que la productividad tenía que ver con
este rollo de los hábitos tal vez muchos
de ustedes se ubican que son los hábitos
voy a tratar de desglosar se los de
forma rápida el hábito se requiere
conocimiento habilidad y motivación el
conocimiento y la habilidad es cómo
contestar el qué y el cómo la motivación
contesta el por qué las dos primeras
aparecen como una sola vez en la
ecuación pero la motivación requiere
estar vigente siempre es por eso que los
malos hábitos son tan fácil de
adquirirlos porque la motivación está
relacionada con el placer y entonces
esto nos permite repetir repetir repetir
hasta que de alguna manera se incorpora
el desafío es incorporar a nuestra vida
un hábito que es no tan motivante por
ejemplo quiero tener una vida saludable
pues necesitamos buscar el por qué
queremos la vida saludable para poder
enfocarnos ahí y que eso funcione como
motivador porque por supuesto muchos de
ustedes sabrán qué
leer un libro cada mes oa un nuevo
idioma requiere de esfuerzo guardar hay
que enfocarnos en el porqué más profundo
yo siempre he dicho que no es lo mismo
querer que desear porque hay gente que
dice yo quiero tener una vida saludable
pero desea comerse el pastel de
chocolate por ejemplo y se lo comen
hay quien dice oye yo quiero ser muy
productivo pero desean estar entrando a
redes sociales para ver si alguien
cambió el estatus a tiene una relación o
algo así entonces se va perdiendo la
productividad
desarrolle siete pasos que voy a tratar
de compartir se los en forma rápida con
un ejemplo cada uno con la intención de
que ustedes puedan adquirir algo de esta
información y que lo puedan quizás
capitalizar en su vida el primero es la
actitud la actitud de alguna manera es
algo bastante difícil en una sociedad en
donde estamos muy cargados de
negatividad le voy a poner un ejemplo si
ustedes salen por ejemplo a caminar y le
dicen a un amigo oye qué bonito está el
día es muy probable que el amigo les
diga pues a ver si no llueve a la tarde
o sea todo si hay un grupo de amigas y
alguien dice que creen estoy embarazada
después de los gritos las felicitaciones
se oye un murmullo por allá en el fondo
que dice duerme duerme lo que pueda no
es decir ahí viene el niño y te va a
dejar noches de desvelo siempre
intentamos opacar las cosas como
positivas piénsenlo bien y la actitud se
requiere se requiere para ser productivo
le voy a poner un reto es un ejercicio
sencillo pondré algo en la pantalla lo
dejaré solamente unos segundos luego lo
quito y ustedes me dicen que vieron les
parece
que vieron
murciélagos quien vio murciélago
levanten la mano quienes vieron los
murciélagos van ok alguien de ustedes
vio ángeles
te vas a ir al cielo te vas al cielo
derechito pues ahí están los ángeles los
ángeles están no tengo mucho tiempo para
explicárselos pero si concentran su
vista en lo blanco y hacen que lo negro
se vaya para el fondo van a empezar a
salir los ángeles pero con esto les
demuestro que el cerebro está muy
cargado a ver lo obscuro lo negro el
problema el conflicto por eso tenemos
que trabajar en la actitud ok si no los
han visto no se preocupen se confiesan
mañana y quedó todo arreglado
planeación trataré de explicar este
punto de una manera muy sencilla la
gente productiva hace lo que tiene que
hacer en el momento en que lo tiene que
hacer con este ejemplo va a quedar un
poco claro imagínense que yo les digo
que tenemos que ahorrar 12 mil pesos en
un año esto significa que deberíamos de
ahorrar mil pesos por mes porque tenemos
12 meses están de acuerdo que algo así
más o menos se vería la cosa una
monedita de mil pesos cada mes que hace
la mayoría de la gente
correcto en noviembre está diciendo hijo
es un nuevo grado nada cómo le hago
tengo que juntar como cuatro o cinco
ahorita nomás ganó tres y entonces van
con un amigo y le dicen que crees me
puse una meta bien desafiante
estoy bien retador entonces voy a tener
que cambiarla de alguna forma no es que
la tengas que cambiar el problema es que
no hiciste la tarea cuando la tenías que
hacer
el siguiente punto de la prioridad lo
voy a explicar de una forma sencilla la
prioridad tiene que ver con lo que es
importante para nosotros que amamos que
queremos por lo general es la gente que
tenemos cerca y que muchas veces la
dejamos en segundo plano pero también
hay otra parte en la prioridad que tiene
que ver con lo que es importante para la
trascendencia de nosotros les voy a
explicar un ejemplo que hago en algunos
de los cursos que doy en los talleres no
lo vamos a hacer aquí yo ahorita les
explico por qué pero en los talleres le
digo a la gente saquen su celular
manden un mensaje a la persona que
ustedes quieran elijan a la persona de
su lista de contactos puede ser su
esposa su hijo quien quieran pero el
mensaje solo debe de decir esto hola te
quiero
lo que sucede es que pasan tres cosas
una te contestan
yo también lo que te valida que
habitualmente dices te quiero la segunda
es que te contestan con está todo bien
como pensando que algo está mal va y la
tercera que también sucede es que la
gente dice a su madre este se va a matar
entonces te marcan por teléfono porque
piensan que estás en la orillita para
aventar te quieren salvar no entonces te
marcan por eso no vamos a hacer el
ejercicio porque tendríamos que cancelar
el que con tanta llamada verdad lo que
pero es una forma de que ustedes chequen
si habitualmente le dicen a la gente que
te aman que los quieren lo que los aman
por otro lado está la trascendencia y la
forma en que trató de ayudar a la gente
a encontrar esto es que les digo piensa
en quién admiras si tú tienes una
persona que admiras encontrarás tres o
cuatro cosas de él porque las admiras y
esos son los valores y los valores se
relacionan con algo que a ti te llama la
atención si tus metas las pones
relacionadas con esto hay mayor
probabilidad de que se logren el
siguiente la proyección sencilla es
ponernos a trabajar el estudio que vimos
pero arropado con lo que les estoy
explicando de esta manera el trabajo
agarra una dirección diferente
hay un buen dicho que dijo henry fueren
donde dice todo es posible si lo
dividimos en pequeñas metas o en
pequeñas tareas y tiene razón cuando la
meta sea muy grande hagan división en
pequeñas tareas pequeños logros y esto
les va ayudando a que lleguen al punto
la empatía ahora estas tres tienen que
ver con las relaciones que tenemos con
la gente la empatía se las explicaré de
esta manera nadie que es productivo está
contento cuando alguien alrededor está
triste busca la manera de que la gente
que está alrededor se sienta bien hace
tiempo escuché que un maestro de
psicología les puso un examen a sus
alumnos que estaban por graduarse la
última pregunta decía ustedes están por
graduarse si contestan esta pregunta
pasarán el examen necesito que me digan
el nombre de la persona que ha hecho el
aseo por más de 10 años en esta
institución
nadie aprobó
la gente productiva lo que hace es que
empieza a ver la gente que es invisible
para los demás eso es empatía
la comunicación se las trataré de contar
en forma rápida hay dos formas en donde
quiero que presten la atención a la
comunicación la primera es lo que nos
decimos nosotros mismos nos decimos
ciertas cosas todos los días todos los
días la gente productiva se habla en
positivo la gente productiva no puede
hablarse negativo porque los
pensamientos se convierten en
sentimientos y los sentimientos en
hechos por otro lado tenemos la
comunicación asertiva debemos de
asegurarnos que la comunicación que
tenemos sea buena pondré un ejemplo a
los 21 años puse mi primer negocio
vendía computadoras un amigo de la
cuadra me ayudaba en el negocio un día
me habló y me dijo necesitamos mandar
una cotización porque un cliente me lo
está pidiendo entonces yo le dije bien
saca el cajón del cajón saca un libro en
donde están ahí los precios del
proveedor del precio que venga y la
computadora supone un 30% arriba yo
estaba buscando mi ganancia
lo hizo textual puso el costo y puso un
30 arriba
ese día aprendí que tenía que prestar
mucha atención a cómo comunicaba las
cosas por supuesto sigue siendo mi amigo
hay un cliente con una computadora bien
barata y mucha gente preguntándose qué
significa ese 30% ahora ustedes ya lo
saben para usted pero aprendí a que
tenía que comunicarme de mejor manera la
innovación
la gente productiva busca la forma de
reinventarse todos los días cuando un
camino empieza a encontrar obstáculos
entonces busca la posibilidad de irse
por otro lado alguien pensó que de esto
nos podíamos ir a esto y luego alguien
más pensó que de esto nos podíamos ir a
esto la gente que es productiva siempre
está pensando en nuevos caminos en
nuevas formas de reinventarse
quiero terminar la plática con dos
reflexiones la primera es que hay un
dicho por ahí que dice que todo queda
lejos cuando uno no quiere ir
encuentren el motivador que los hace ir
hacia dónde quieren ir la segunda es
algo que escuche hace mucho tiempo y que
me ha hecho mucho eco durante toda mi
vida stephen covey una vez dijo que la
gente recarga su escalera de la vida en
paredes y que les cuesta mucho trabajo
ir subiendo los peldaños de esa escalera
para luego darse cuenta que lo que hay
detrás de la barda no era lo que querían
para su vida así es que yo les invito a
que agarren la escalera de su vida
la recarga en la pared correcta para que
cuando lleguen arriba se den cuenta que
lo que está del otro lado es exactamente
lo que habían soñado muchísimas gracias